I mean the guys in that Prince Movie,
Purple Rain,
that shit was so gay fucking 80 style.
It was sitting and I was gone.
What about the time?
There's no doubt that every era of
movies looks back on previous era's one
full generation before.
It's far enough back to reflect on while
still being fresh.
So it's pretty common for directors and
producers to make movies and TV shows
that take place in that previous
generation in the generation they grew
up in.
It's a wonderful life goes from the
forties to the twenties back to the
future goes from the eighties to the
fifties and that's 70 show goes from the
two thousands to the seventies and the
same thing goes for the 2010 looking
back on the 1980s but this era seems to
have more of a craze than a simple Omaj
to the eighties countless movies and TV
shows,
gift,
meticulous detail to the movies,
video games,
and overall style of that era,
all to critical acclaim and box office
success.
Nothing encapsulates our current
obsession with the 1980s more than ready
player one a novel turned movie about a
future world where people use virtual
reality to relive old eighties pop
culture and media.
It doesn't get more eighties obsessed
than that.
I think there are several reasons.
The eighties phenomenon is so much more
prominent than the nostalgia of other
generations.
For one thing,
the eighties was the birth of audio
visual entertainment with the music
video creating a whole new art form that
continues to influence movies today.
It was also the golden age of TV movies.
The teens watching those movies have
since become the movie creators and
creating thematically complicated
teenagers paved the way for casting more
kids in lead roles.
But I want to focus on the eighties
phenomenon for another reason,
entirely the perfect timing of the 80s
created movies designed to be Omaj to
later on movies begging to be revisited,
and that's because of how the directors
and producers made them.
And to understand the eighties creators,
you have to understand where they came
from.
Mid Sixties till late seventies films in
a period referred to as new age
Hollywood.
We're defined by deviation from
classical cinematic norms.
These films questioned the Hollywood
system,
creating more experimental movies,
movies that challenge John or norms,
conventional filming techniques and the
Hollywood production code.
Maybe the pinnacle of new age.
Hollywood was Bonnie and Clyde,
a movie with insane violence,
sexually confused characters and
counterculture sentiment.
And in this hotbed of cinematic
experimentation came the pioneers of the
80s blockbuster,
the creative talent with a hyper
awareness of Hollywood conventions,
conventions.
They themselves knew how to abide by
when they wanted and break when they
didn't.
So the eventual leaders of the 80s
blockbuster where the first generation
of filmmakers to grow up during
classical Hollywood and then rise to the
top during a period of extreme
experimentation.
So their film language is based on
previous films and their style is driven
by how they follow or break film
conventions.
And how do I know that's how they made
their movies?
Because online there's a transcript of
perhaps the two most important eighties
directors conceiving the idea for one of
the best movies of the 1980s Steven
Spielberg and George Lucas Discussing
Indiana Jones,
raiders of the lost Ark.
A lot of people enjoy reading the banter
between the two directors and how they
thought of the iconic sequences in the
movie.
But I want to discuss these transcripts
with a new Hollywood eighties Omaj
perspective because as you read it,
you realize how their entire means of
communicating comes from building off of
previous movies.
Lucas pitched the movie as a Spaghetti
Western or James Bond,
but in the 30s they describe me,
Indiana Jones by comparing him to other
movie characters,
he's professional like me,
food aid from the seven Samurai,
he has to go against people like Eli
Wallace from the good,
the bad and the ugly.
He's a John Wayne,
Clint Eastwood,
Sean Connery,
kind of professional but scruffy like
Humphrey bogart in treasure of Sierra
Madre.
The action should be like the wind and
the lion and the jungle is King Kong
ish.
There.
Language is built on entirely Oman and
in doing so,
they create a completely fresh character
and story by using old movies.
But it's more than just using old to
create new.
These creators also want it to capture
the spirit of movies before new age
Hollywood movies with less social
commentary and more classic Hollywood
find a movie to instill.
The eighties mindset was undoubtedly
star wars in 1977 George Lucas describes
the phenomenon himself.
My main reason for making star wars was
to give young people an honest,
wholesome fantasy life.
The kinds my generation had.
We had westerns,
pirate movies,
all kinds of great things.
Where are the romance,
the adventure,
and the fun that used to be in
practically every movie ever made.
He criticized the 70s TV shows at the
time,
like Kojak and the 6 million men that
were popular and well made,
but also extremely bleak and almost too
realistic.
Basically they missed out on the fun.
So the 80s blockbuster brought back what
made movies entertaining in the first
place?
James Cameron's the terminator is
inspired by 1950 Psi Phi and the outer
limits,
uh,
1960 Scifi show,
as are a lot of other eighties movies
like e t and ghostbusters.
And notice how these later movies don't
make aliens horrific or bleak.
They make aliens whimsical and fun.
Even the princess bride,
a fantasy movie seems to perfectly
capture the George Lucas and Steven
Spielberg spirit.
Many sixties and seventies teen movies
are defined by their oversized
characters or plots with extreme sexual
deviations.
This is Robinson you're trying to
seduce.
John Hughes was one of the first to
create an honest portrayal of teenagers,
one defined by clumsy romance and
entertaining hi-jinks.
I think Roger Ebert sums up what these
eighties creators accomplished in his
review of Indiana Jones.
This movie celebrates the stories we
spent our adolescent searching for in
the pulpit adventure magazines in the
novels,
in comics,
even in the movies.
So I think that's the biggest reason why
eighties movies are so popular today and
why stranger things has dozens of
eighties movies.
References.
San Junipero won two emmy's and it is
the highest grossing horror movie of all
time.
The movies of the 80s capture the spirit
of entertainment and these modern Oh
matias want to do the same when you
watch another 80s movie made in the
present day,
notice how there's almost always some
shot where we see what blockbuster is
currently out in theaters at the time.
Eighties movies reinvigorated that
Hollywood blockbuster and that's why we
look back to that time period when we're
trying to do the same today.
So the next time you see a big budget
eighties movie coming out,
remember there's some part of that
director trying to capture the spirit
that made 80s movies so timeless and fun
to watch because they really did have
everything
sporks in it.
I you kidding?
Same Shane fighting torture,
revenge,
giant monsters,
chases,
escapes,
troll love miracles.
Those are some too bad we're trying to
stay away.
This video is brought to you by
squarespace lets you create your own
website without needing to code.
It's got some award winning templates
that work for all kinds of people.
Whether you're a musician and artist or
you want to start your own blog,
go to squarespace.com/now you see it to
get a free trial and 10% off your first
purchase.
Go to this link and choose a template to
instantly get started with your sleek,
easy to use website in the next couple
of months.
I think I want to start my own website
and squarespace is going to be my first
place to go.
Thanks for watching.
[inaudible].